you can't miss it it's a huge Burning
Man style Art Exhibit that's now at the
commercial center right so it's part of
the County's fabulous commercial center
block party the whole idea is to really
revive that area right out in Sahara
kind of the commercial area Candace
Charles joins us live from the
commercial center with a history about
the center and really the goal behind
this block party to just keep that area
alive good morning
good morning YouTube good morning folks
Seth this area has Rich history we've
heard that the doors have been down here
Liberace himself as well as Jimi Hendrix
just to name a few I'm standing right in
between the two huge art installations
that will be here the forest house where
dead mouse will be performing as well as
El pupil mechanico first time in Vegas
from burning man now Clark County has
teamed up with the UNLV arts department
as well as Insomniac fired up management
to bring you guys this block party and
have Clark County Commissioner tick
cigar room here with me thank you so
much for joining us tell us a little bit
about what has happened in this area and
how you're trying to revive it well back
in the 60s this was the standard culture
and entertainment and the first original
Shopping Center in Las Vegas but since
that time it's gone downhill but it's
still a great open space you can't find
a piece of property this big this close
to the strip and so we're trying to
revitalize it bring it back but also in
the process celebrating Las Vegas
history because one thing we do is we're
great about tearing down structures and
building new ones but we never talk
about who we used to be and that's where
Liberace and Frank Sinatra and the doors
and all these groups let's bring those
back too and talk about how they played
a role in our future and how and how
going forward
this is this is going to be a great
place it's going to be different
restaurants different bars any place
where you can no cover charge you can
walk from place to place and just
celebrate yes it sounds like it'll be a
good time this Thursday really kicking
it off those tickets sold out in about
three hours we're talking about 12 000
tickets that were sold our souls excuse
me got given away for free even better
3.99 right so tell me a little bit about
uh the events that you guys expect to
have coming up after this I know there's
going to be more absolutely the account
he actually owns this parking lot so
we're going to make this into an Arts
installation feature partnering with
different artists different with you and
and then have the concerts like this
other kind of events outside food trucks
things like that but just a place where
people can come and not have a cover
charge which is real important for the
locals so this is going to be a place
where Las Vegas celebrate themselves I
love that
early and you can find out more details
about this amazing event on our website
newsnow.com now as I mentioned about
maybe ten thousand twelve thousand
people are expected to be down here on
Thursday starting at about six o'clock
so expect a little bit of traffic as
well as having police presence they're
also suggesting that you go ahead and
use those right apps to get down here to
alleviate some of that traffic and I
just heard there's been an addition
added to these setlists Mix Master DJ
Mike from the Beastie Boys we'll also be
here so it's going to be quite a part of
you guys again it's the first time
they're gonna be kicking off events here
and we'll have details on that coming up
as we hear about it so stick with us for
the latest for now live from the
commercial center I'm Candace Charles
eight news now sounds like fun Candace
thank you very much we'll keep it
covered all right